how do you think
through an idea well first of all i i
think okay
that's a really good question
we tried to work that out with this
essay app that my son and i have
developed because if you're going to
write the first question is well what
should i write about
what's the name of the app sa.app
and
well the first question is
well what bugs you
what's bugging you
this is such a cool thing it's like
where is my destiny
well what bothers you well that's where
your destiny is your destiny is to be
found in what bothers you
why do those things bother you there's a
lot of things you could be bothered by
like a million things man but some
things grip you
they bug you and they might make you
resentful and bitter because they bug
you so much like they're your things man
they've got you
so then
i look for a question that i would like
the answer to
that i don't and i would really like the
answer to it
so i don't assume i already have the
answer because i would actually really
like to have the answer
so if i could get a better
answer great and so that's the first
thing and that's like a prayer it's like
okay
here's a mystery i would like
to
delve into it further
well so that's humility it's like here's
a mystery which means i don't know i
would like to delve into it further
which means i don't know enough already
and then
then comes the revelation
it's like
well what's a revelation well if you ask
yourself a question
it's a real question
do you get an answer or not
the answer is well yeah thoughts start
to appear in your head
so from somewhere that's right from
somewhere where do they come from do you
have a sense
depends on what you're aiming at
depends on the question well no it don't
it does to some degree
it depends it depends on your intent
so imagine that your intent is to make
things better
then maybe they come from the place
that's designed to make things better
maybe your intent is to make things
worse
then they come from hell
and you think not really it's like
you're so sure about that are you is
your intent conscious like are you able
um
conscious and habitual right because as
you practice something consciously it
becomes habitual but it's conscious it's
like i when i sit down
before i do a lecture i think okay
what's the goal here
to do the best job i can
to what end well people are coming here
not for political issues they're coming
here because they're trying to make
their lives better okay so what are we
doing we're conducting a joint
investigation into the nature of that
which makes life better okay what's my
role to do as good a job about that as
possible what state of mind do i have to
be in am i annoyed about the theater
or am i do am i clued in and thrilled
that 4 000 people have showed up at
substantial expense and trouble to come
and listen to me talk
and if i'm not in that state of mind i
think well maybe i need something to eat
or maybe i need to talk to someone
because
that
ingratitude is no place to start it's
like i should be thrilled to be there
obviously and so that that orientation
has to be there and then i said
conscious all this is conscious what am
i serving the highest good i can
conceptualize what is that i have some
sense but i don't know it in the final
analysis which is why the investigation
is being conducted who's doing it me
whoever i'm communing with and the
audience
and so i want i try to get myself and i
chase everybody away for that it's like
i have to do that by myself are you
writing stuff down
yes at that point i make no i just make
point notes and it's usually about maybe
30 notes but then i on stage i never
refer to them and i often don't even use
the structure that i laid out
kind of an interesting thing from where
do powerful phrases come from do you
have a do you have a
do you try to encapsulate an idea into a
sentence or two
well i
when i talk
i practice this since consciously since
1985
i try to feel
and see
if the words are stepping stones or
foundation stones right it's like is
this solid is this word solid is this
phrase solid is this sentence solid like
it's a real sense of
fundamental foundation under each word
and i suppose people ask me if i pray
and i would say i pray before every word
well when you're when you're asking
questions like you're very
clear
headed
and present in your
ability to ask questions and inquire so
how do you do that
so first of all
i'm worried that
my mind easily gets trapped
when i step on a word and i know
it's unstable
you kind of realize that you don't
really know the definitions of any words
you use
and that can be
debilitating
so i kind of try to be more carefree
about the words i use
because otherwise you get trapped you
don't want to be obsessional
like literally my mind halfway through
the sentence will think
well
what does the word sentence mean right
right right well you know
everything else just explodes your big
picture idea explodes and you lost
yourself in the minutia well
neurologically
there's a production center
and an editing center
and those can be separately affected by
strokes
and so
often when people are writing or talking
they try to activate both at the same
time
and that's so people will try to write
an essay and get every sentence right
the first draft that's a big mistake and
so then you might say well how can you
be careful with your words but carefree
and the answer is
orient yourself properly right well in
the conversation we're having you you
have an orientation structure you want
to
be prepared you want to be attentive
then you want to have an interesting
conversation
and you want to have the kind of
interesting conversation that other
people want to listen to
that will be good for them in some
manner
okay so that's pretty good frame
and and then you kind of scour your
heart and you think is that really what
you want are you after fame or after
notoriety are you after money i'm not
saying any of those things are
necessarily bad
but
they're not optimal especially if you're
not willing to admit them right and so
they can contaminate you so you want to
be decontaminated so you have the right
trip let's say
and
and so you have to put yourself that's a
meditative practice you have to put
yourself in the right receptive position
with the right goal in mind then
you can
and i think you can get better and
better at this then you can trust
what's going to happen
you know so for example before i came
here
i i mean i presume you have a reason for
doing the podcast
with me
what's the reason
um
i mean we
wanted to talk for a long time so the
reason has evolved
the
one of
the reasons is i've listened to you
uh for quite a long time so you become a
one-way friend
and i have many one-way friends some of
my best friends don't even know i exist
so i'm a big fan of podcasts and
audiobooks actually most of my friends
are dead yeah right um
the writers the definition of a reader
with a lot of dead great dead friends so
i wanted i wanted to meet this one-way
friend i suppose didn't have a
conversation and then there's this kind
of
puzzle that i've been longing to solve
the same reason i went to ukraine
of asking this question of myself
who am i
and what was this part of the world what
is this thing that happened in the 20th
century
that i lost so much my family there
and i feel so much of my family is
defined by that place
now that place includes the soviet union
it includes
russia and ukraine it includes nazi
germany includes these
big powerful leaders
and huge
millions of people that were
lost
in the beauty the power of the dream but
were also
uh the
torture
that
was forced onto them through different
governmental
institutions
and you are somebody that seemed from
some angle
to
also be drawn to try to understand what
was that and not in some sort of
historical sense but in a deeply
psychological human sense what is that
will it repeat again in what way is it
repeating again and how can we stop it
and how can we stop it and so that's the
crucial issue i
felt i wanted to
from a very different backgrounds
the pull at the threat of that curiosity
you know i'm an engineer
you're
a psychologist
both lost in that curiosity and uh
both were suits
and a talk with various levels of
eloquence um
about sort of um
the shadows that these that that history
uh
cast on us
and so that was one and also the
psychology i wanted to be a psychiatrist
for a long time i was uh
i was fascinated by the human mind
and until i discovered artificial
intelligence the fact that i could
program and make a robot move and
until i discovered that magic
i thought i wanted to understand the
human mind by being psychiatrist by
talking to people by uh through to talk
therapy psychotherapy now you've got the
best of both worlds because you get to
talk to people and you get build robots
yeah i mean but the dream ultimately is
the robot
that i felt like by building the
thinking you start to try to understand
it yeah that's one way i mean we're all
we all have different skills and
proclivities so like my particular one
is uh has to do with
uh i learn by building yeah i i think
through a thing but building it and
programming is a wonderful thing because
it allows you to like build a little toy
example so in the same way you can do a
little thought experiment
uh programming allows you to create a
thought experiment in action it can move
it can live and can right and then you
can ask questions of it so all of those
because of my interest in freud and
young
you're also in different ways
have have
delved deeply into
um into humanity the human psyche
through the perspective of those of
those
psychologists so all for all those
reasons i thought our password across
yeah so that well so that's quite a
frame for a discussion right you had all
sorts of reasons and then you think
well are you just letting the
conversation go where it will it's like
well not exactly
you spent all this time
it's not like this came about by
accident this conversation you spent all
this time framing it and so
all of that provides the implicit
substructure for the play in the
conversation and if you have that
implicit here's another way this is very
much worth knowing is
if you get the implicit structure of
perception right everything becomes a
game
and not only that a game you want to
play and maybe in the final analysis a
game you'd want to play forever
so
you know that's obviously a distant
beckoning ideal but
we known games need rules
or there's no play
is there a device you can give
now that we know the frame
to give to me lex about
how to
do this podcast better how to
think
about this world how to be a good
engineer
how to uh be a good human being
from where you take your preoccupation
with suffering seriously
it's a serious business
right and that's part of that to circle
back to the beginning let's say
that's that willingness to gaze into the
abyss which is obviously what you were
doing when you went to ukraine
it's like
it's gazing into the abyss that makes
you better
the thing is and this is maybe where
nietzsche's
idea is not as differentiated as it
became
sometimes your gaze can be forcefully
directed towards the abyss
and then you're traumatized
if it's involuntary and accidental it
can kill you
the more it's voluntary
the more transformative it is and that's
part of that idea about facing death and
hell
it's like can you tolerate death in hell
and the answer is
this terrible answer is
yes
to the degree that you're willing to do
it
voluntarily and then you might ask well
why should i have to subject myself to
death in hell i'm innocent
and then the answer to that is
even the innocent must be voluntarily
sacrificed to the highest good
that's such an interesting distinction
voluntary stuff voluntary yeah
yeah well that's why the central
christian doctrine is
pick up your cross and follow me
and i'm speaking
not in religious terms saying that i'm
just speaking as a psychologist it's
like one of the things we've learned in
the last hundred years is
voluntary exposure to that which
freezes and terrifies you in measured
proportions is curative
you